benjamin break publicado en redes
sociales las fotos de su viaje a irán
que comenzó en 2018 un apasionado de
viajar por el mundo en su furgoneta
la última foto publicada en su página es
del 26 de mayo de 2020 la tomó en irán
fue acusado de espiar tras ser
sorprendido haciendo fotografías con su
dron en zonas prohibidas si es declarado
culpable podría enfrentarse a la pena de
muerte pero él niega haber actuado mal
su familia ha tratado de crear
conciencia sobre su difícil situación
en las últimas llamadas que tuve con él
me hizo entender que su situación era
muy difícil que estaba tocando fondo que
ya no era posible ya que jon fosse
alsacia se está volviendo muy duro para
él y por eso hoy ha iniciado una huelga
de hambre es su único recurso se usará
la única forma en que puede intentar
cambiar su situación
los abogados deberían dicen que no es
una espía sino un simple turista han
descrito su detención como una toma de
rehenes por parte del gobierno iraní y
no es el único occidental detenido en el
país la académica franco-iraní fariba
adelca detenida en mayo de 2020 fue de
nuevo encarcelada
los límites de su arresto domiciliario
varios ciudadanos occidentales con doble
nacionalidad están detenidos en la
república islámica